la barre des 4000 800 morts était
franchie en espagne le pays devient le
deuxième état d'europe le plus touché
après l'italie 769 morts en 24 heures
au total plus de 50 7004 contaminations
ont été confirmées sur le sol espagnol
et face à l'urgence de la situation un
immense hôpital de campagne a été montée
dans la foire commerciale de madrid
aujourd'hui nous allons admettre ici 250
260 passion des urgences de madrid c'est
pourquoi nous ouvrons ce pavillon et
nous gardons également ouvert le
pavillon 5 découvert samedi dernier où
320 patients sont déjà dit cela signifie
que ce soir nous allons admettre
ambiante 600 650 passion ali fait mal
ce qui me semble vraiment important nous
avons sondé 1 il semble que nous soyons
un pic d'admission pour le courant des
virus et l'idée est de continuer à ce
rythme d'admission environ 250 stations
à gagner chaque jour le vendredi le
samedi et le dimanche
cela signifie que le dimanche en fin de
journée nous aurons environ 1100
patients admis ici l ifema ce qui est un
nombre très important en une seule
semaine